[MUSIC PLAYING]
DONALD CLARK: Myself and my two
colleagues, Dave and Manasa,
are going to talk you through
a few different aspects
of Google's network and
why we think it makes
for a high performance network.
My section is going
to be taking you
through the basics,
the underlying
physical and operating aspects
of Google, Google's network
that powers Google Cloud.
Going to talk a
little bit how we
plan to build our network for
resilience, how we operate
in a resilient fashion, and
also how we extend this thinking
beyond the boundaries
of our own network
to the internet in general.
So let's start off.
It's possibly no surprise that
Google owns, and operates,
and has built probably one
of the largest networks
in the world.
This network is
primarily based on fiber
that we've let
ourselves or we've even
built ourselves or in
conjunction with partners.
Now, what this
means is that we can
offer a predictable and
resilient performance
level all across the world.
So, if we look at the map,
you can see here these
are all the network
past that we've
built over the 20 or so years
that Google has been running.
Highlighted as well here we
have some of our major submarine
cable investments dating
back to 2010 with Unity,
all the way through to the more
recently announced cables that
are coming on stream
in the coming year.
So this is the network that
enables us to serve billions
of search query answers.
This is the network
that enables us
to serve billions of
hours of YouTube videos
to users all over the world.
And this is also the
network that Google
uses to replicate content and
services between our custom
built data centers
on our footprint
again across the world.
And, critically,
it's the network
that powers Google Cloud.
Now, in recent years, what's
interesting and exciting
for us in the Cloud
team is that it's
our cloud customers and
some of their demands
that have started to shape
the nature of our network
investments and network planning
as we go to new locations
with new mini clusters
a new cloud regions,
and as we have to think
careful about how we connect
in ways that prioritize maybe
latency over resilience.
Let me give you an
example of that.
This is last year.
And you'll see here
that when we built
some new paths between
Singapore, our Southeast Asia
region, and Sydney, we almost
cut our latency in half.
It's actually not
possible to get
that much shorter latency now
between these two locations.
OK.
And this is a great
example of where we've
said latency is important.
Resilience is important.
Let's build more
capacity that makes
sense for our cloud users.
And we're doubling
down in this region.
Later this year we will have
two new cable investments,
the Indigo cable
and the JGA cable
coming on stream to add
even more capacity and more
performance.
What's also interesting
to think about
is that Google is now at
a scale in its operations
that it can go about
planning and building
submarine cables by itself.
What this means is
that we can provide
a level of path certainty.
We can lay the
cable where we need
it to go to connect our
locations that makes sense
for Google and for cloud.
And we can do it
an awful lot faster
than traditional approaches
where you're working
with many consortia partners.
So these things are
called private cables
in the industry parlance.
If you want to read a little bit
more about some private cables
that we've announced, encourage
you to use your favorite search
engine and look up the Curie
cable which is going from Chile
up the west coast into North
America or the Dunant cable,
which there is a press release
about some exciting technology
Dave will talk about
just last week.
But the Dunant cable goes
between France and America
as well.
And these are
private cable systems
Google is building by itself.
And we're able to do that
because of our scale.
Now the great news for all
of you here as Google Cloud
customers is that you're able to
connect to this network at 134
locations all around the world.
That could be directly or
through an extensive network
of Cloud Interconnect partners.
It has never been easier to get
on board our global network.
Now it's great having
a huge network,
but as our traffic grows, and
we build new cloud regions,
and we have to build new
paths for new capacity,
it's also critical that
we maintain and improve
the performance of the network.
Now when we're planning,
we use extensive simulation
whenever we introduce
or consider introducing
new network capacity.
We want to make
sure that it is not
going to impact
our SLOs negatively
or it's not going to do
so in unexpected ways.
And as part of
this, we've actually
evolved our planning processes.
So we used to use trended
historical data on outages
and expected failure rates.
And we'd run some Monte
Carlo type simulations
to actually understand what
the potential SLO would
expect to see was.
Now we've moved beyond
that a little bit.
And we're performing more
discrete event analysis
these days.
So what we do is we
classify a whole batch
of different failure types
across the entire network path.
And we assign each of
them probability curves
and frequency curves of
happening, blast radius,
independency variables.
We then push these all
together and run them
for a fictional 10,
20, 30, 50 years
into the future against a whole
different range of network
topologies.
And what this does is gives
us a reasonably high degree
of certainty that
the network we choose
and the additional capacity
locations and paths
that we add into it is
going to meet, and maintain,
and increase the resilience
and the predictability
that we care so much about.
This sounds like
a lot of bother.
Is it really worth it?
The answer is
really clearly yes.
OK.
Here's an example
from 2018 last year.
We're looking here at two data
centers in our APAC region.
We have a number of paths.
I've obfuscated the data here
slightly for commercial reasons
on the cables.
But you can see we had two
cuts, two jewel case failure
scenarios where we lost
paths on two systems at once.
And in fact, one
of these was what
we call a jewel
case worst failure
where we lost one of
the very large paths.
These are also quite
long, enduring events.
And that's because in
the submarine world,
the actual identification
of a failure
through to the rectification
can take months.
You have to permit.
There's weather issues.
The ship may not be available
to go and do the repair.
It may not find the cable.
It may have to
remake the repair.
Now, fortunately, because of
all of that planning and effort
into building a resilient
network that I talked
about earlier, no Google Cloud
customer and no Google service
was negatively impacted by
these jewel case failure events.
OK.
Things just went on.
And that's what we
try and aim for.
We try very much to not
leave anything to chance
when we're building
out this network.
So now that we've built
it in a resilient manner,
it's critical that we operate
it resiliently as well.
And there's three
aspects to that
that I want to share
with you today.
The first is SDN everywhere.
It's no secret that we've
operated an SDN network
on our core inter-data
center campus network.
However a couple
of years ago, we
announced with Espresso
that we were pushing SDN
right out to the edge.
And that process is effectively
finished as off now.
What does this mean?
Well, it enables us to
maintain a level of performance
and availability right out to
the edge of the network that's
simply not possible using
regular routing approaches
and routing protocols.
We can optimize our link
utilization at the same time
as we maintain certain business
rules, quality of service
aspects, and priorities.
It also offers a lot
faster convergence
than traditional protocols
like MPLS running RSVP.
Secondly, at the
edge of our network,
we connect with nearly all
significant network operators.
And this allows us to hand
off directly and reliably
close to the end user
about 99% of our traffic.
So together these
first two points
translate to higher
availability,
better performance through
Google's Cloud network
than is available through
the internet at large.
But the icing on the cake
is always our SRE teams,
so our site reliability
engineering teams.
If you've not visited
the SRE lounge yet,
it's across in the back corner.
Look for the inflatable unicorn.
Google literally
wrote the book on SRE
and it's available in the
bookshop in the Swank corner.
We have a number of
network SRE teams
stationed throughout the world.
And it's their role to
continually respond and adapt
to network events to improve
systems and processes so
that the reliability and
performance of the network
continues to improve over time.
It's a classic
post-mortem culture.
If something goes wrong,
we don't blame people.
We identify root cause.
We learn and we implement
approaches and workarounds
to build a resilience
and a performance that
only goes one way, up.
Our SRE teams are
also on hand to give
a second level of support
to our customer facing staff
and help on some deep
cloud issues that
may require a little
bit more involvement
on the actual network layer.
So together we
operate for resilience
across these three levels.
But our network, your
traffic, our traffic,
doesn't stop at the
edge of our network.
OK.
The internet is a critical
part of how all of us
deliver traffic to end
users to our customers.
And it will continue to be so.
So our commitment to
performance and to reliability
and trustworthiness goes
beyond the edge of our network
to the internet at large.
Now as many of you
know, the reality
is the internet is not
a controlled space.
Bad stuff happens.
Issues like right hijacks
are a fact of life.
OK.
Unfortunately, a keyboard
error by a small ISP in Africa
can really cause
global problems.
As maybe some of you remember
from news articles last year,
they hit Google.
So that's not great.
So here's an example.
We've got a bad actor.
They're doing a couple of
things that's not ideal.
Let's assume it's not malicious.
It's just a keyboard mistake.
Anyone could make it.
They're going to advertise
some of Google's IP space
towards their peers.
They're also advertising
some IP space
from another network out
towards the internet.
Well, today these routes are
going to start to propagate
and traffic could
go the wrong way.
OK.
User traffic could end
up in black holes, being
isolated, just bad things.
So this is not great.
And we've seen this
happen too many times.
What's Google trying
to do about this?
OK.
Well, firstly, we're continually
enhancing our own monitoring
and filtering capabilities.
We want to make sure we
can get quicker and better
at identifying these sorts of
issues and responding to them.
However, this is a
community wide issue.
And so we are working with other
organizations in partnership.
We've joined MANRS.
For those of you
who've not heard of it,
is the best acronym
in the world, MANRS,
the Mutually Agreed Norms
for Routing Security.
It is an ISOC sponsored group.
And it's really working
to try and enhance
the security of routing
on the internet.
So Google has recently joined.
And I can announce
that shortly we
will start applying
routing filters
based on the routing
registry IRR to all
of our public peering sessions.
So we want to slowly encourage
other network operators
to up their game in maintaining
the accuracy and veracity
of those IRR records.
Now that's great, but it's going
to take a little bit of time.
Anything on the
internet takes time.
Hopefully, this will be
faster than IPv6 everywhere.
So the other thing we're doing
is something called peer lock.
And so peer lock we think
will give us some short term
immediate gain.
And we're going to work
with about 15 or 20
of our largest peering
partners to effectively bring
an additional level of filtering
safety, which will validate
not just the addresses
but also the paths that we
wish to receive
those addresses from.
So together with
these two aspects,
we believe that a lot of
these negative situations
will be blocked.
It's going to bring
additional valuable protection
and stability, not
just to Google traffic
but, because we're such a
large part of the internet,
to the internet as a whole.
And, of course, because
this is the network that
drives and powers your
traffic to customers,
it'll help Google
Cloud customers as well
and overall deliver a
better internet for cloud.
That's enough about
our underlying network.
I'm going to hand over
to my colleague Dave.
DAVE PHILLIPS: Well, thank
you very much, Donald.
My name is Dave, Dave Phillips.
I'm a colleague of Donald's.
So here to talk to you
about the performance
we have on the Google network.
I'll do that by talking about
three layers of performance.
Right.
We'll talk about
the overall network
software and the algorithms that
we use, you use to talk to us
and we used to talk
between our own services.
We'll talk about
the physical layer
and how that applies directly
to you and gives you benefit.
And we'll talk about the
Andromeda cloud layer,
so where all of your
cloud services live.
And the main message I
want you to take away
is that really at every layer
of the network, every level
of performance, there's
engineering teams within Google
working to optimize, get
a little bit of advantage,
make things faster, make
things more resilient,
and big investment all
the way through it.
So in the last three years,
we've spent $30 billion
on infrastructure.
That's three zero and
billion with a B. Sundar
announced this year we're
spending $13 billion,
so one three and again
billion with a B.
So let's start to look
at some of these layers
and the innovation
we have about them.
OK.
So maybe starting
off, let's just
give you a snapshot of
the timeline of some
of the innovations we've had.
And I guess some of the
things you'll maybe notice
is that some of the
things in the timeline
show up a few years after we've
had them live for a while.
So there's stuff that's on the
timeline that you can't see,
that you'll see a
few years from now.
Somebody will have
this presentation
and there'll be stuff there.
But that's just how it goes.
But a lot of the stuff that's
public right now, well, Donald
talked about SDN.
That's a real core
of what we do.
SDN is the central software
controlled way of doing things.
Think about your modern
way of navigating
what maps when it's got
real time traffic versus how
you used to use a
satnav 15 years ago
and it was a fixed map.
And if everybody went
the same direction,
it was actually slower.
Right.
So that's SDN with
central software control.
Our first iteration
of this was B4.
This is our massive
backbone between all
of our data centers.
We then introduced our Jupiter,
which is our massive switching
fabric that goes within
our data centers,
makes all these tens, hundreds
of thousands of machines
act together as one
great big system.
Andromeda, the network software
defined virtualization layer
that you guys use for
building up your cloud,
and Espresso, which Donald
mentioned the fort pillar which
is taking that software
defined capability
all the way out to the edge.
Other things here, Maglev,
our software defined--
I'm sorry, our load balancer.
That's been in
place at Google now
for maybe more than 10 years
taking in all of our front end
traffic.
And why all of these base
building block infrastructures
are very important is we solved
these problems like Google
to scale to the level we
needed to to be able to deliver
traffic for Google.
But these are the
same building blocks
that are in use for
the cloud products.
You get to use these
same building blocks.
I guess I should hold this
instead of putting it down,
right?
OK.
So we said we'd talk
about these three layers.
Let's talk about performance
at the network software layer.
So as Donald mentioned, we want
to make the internet better
as a whole, so not just
ourselves internally
but overall, because we
make it better for everybody
and everybody adopts
these standards,
everything gets faster.
So let me tell you
about two technologies
here I'll talk about BBR
and I'll talk about QUIC.
So let's talk about BBR first.
OK.
So this is an algorithm within--
a manner of implementing
congestion control within TCP.
So TCP for the longest
time was loss-based.
From the late 1980s, it's
pretty much been loss-based.
Now that's worked
for a long time.
But when you talk about modern
networks, which typically have
high capacity links but
relatively small buffers,
actually this is not such
a great way of doing it.
When TCP algorithms
detect loss, they
can back off quite sharply.
And actually,
counterintuitively,
on very high capacity
networks, sometimes you
don't get such great
performance on that.
So we need to rethink
that from the ground up.
BBR is a way of doing that.
BBR stands for bottleneck
bandwidth round trip
propagation time.
It's a fundamentally
different way
of looking at
congestion control.
And what it does is detects
actual congestion and models
throughput end to end
to be able to optimize
rather than being loss-based.
It gives us a very, very
significant advantage.
There's a nice
little graphic here.
Because it's able to detect
the actual congestion
rather than reacting very
aggressively to loss,
you get much greater throughput.
When we enabled this
on YouTube, overall
globally we got 4%
greater transmit
rate, 14% in some countries.
These are actually big numbers,
because that was really highly
optimized to begin with.
OK.
Now very easy for
you to use that.
As soon as you talk
from your front end
to your back ends
in Google Cloud,
you're already using this.
As soon as you go to anything
which terminates on the Google
side, your sessions from then
on are automatically using BBR.
Right.
So you get that.
So when you're doing
big transactions
rather back to Google Cloud
Storage or anything like that,
you're using this BBR.
You're taking advantage of it.
You're getting that throughput.
Let's change tracks.
Let's talk about
another innovation.
Let's talk about QUIC.
QUIC is quick UDP
internet connections.
And what this is doing is a
way of optimizing your setup so
where you would have used
HTTPS and TLS over TCP.
OK.
Now when you do
that traditionally,
with using HTTPS using
TCP and TLS over TCP--
sorry, over TCP--
you're typically
taking about three
round trips to get
that initial setup, three way
handshakes for that to happen.
With QUIC, if you've already
talked with the server,
you can begin transmitting
traffic immediately.
Right.
So very quick, especially
for that first page load.
When we enable that,
we're seeing about 8%
faster page load.
Again, these were
highly optimized things
to begin with so that's
actually a big number.
How you enable
that yourselves is
on your load balancer inside
the system you just enable QUIC.
Very easy to do.
QUIC is also very, very good.
It was designed from the ground
up for multiplex streams.
So traditionally
with TCP, if you
have some multiplex streams,
you lose some traffic,
all streams are held up.
With QUIC, it's just the actual
stream that's lost the traffic.
The other streams are good.
So also very good for
moving between wireless
and mobile networks as
you may be doing here,
because you have a connection
ID rather than a table.
So again, these are ways
we're optimizing things
at the fundamental
software algorithm layer
to make things faster.
Let's talk about
that second thing
I mentioned, which is let's
talk about improvements
at the physical layer and
how they manifest to you.
Well, so this graphic here
you may have seen some press
about last week.
This is our Dunant transatlantic
cable that we just announced.
Donald mentioned this.
So this is our
second private cable.
We actually have 13
sub-sea cable investments.
So what that means
for you, firstly,
is that we we're going to have
that deterministic capacity
available for you when you need
it with a lot of innovation
at this layer.
So this cable here is going
from Virginia to France.
And normally when
you're in a data center
and you see like a fiber
tray, or a duct, or a trench,
you see hundreds of cables
or thousands of fibers.
Right.
Subsea, it's very,
very different.
The amount of power you need
to regenerate those signals
means in a typical
subsea cable you
have at most maybe six or
eight fiber pairs within that.
This cable here, Dunant
cable, this uses something
called space division
multiplexing.
And it's the first cable
undersea to do that.
It means we can reuse
some of the same repeaters
from multiple fiber pairs
instead of just one.
So this system
here, this actually
has 12 cables, world first.
Right.
So a lot of innovation
at that level right
at the physical layer.
We name all of our cables
after famous scientists.
So Curie.
Dunant was the first
Nobel Prize winner.
The next one will be E and
so think of a scientist
beginning with E. You can
guess what that will be.
Maybe we can have a competition.
I don't actually genuinely know
what the cable will be called.
A and B where alphas and betas.
OK.
So linking back to that, so
why does all this matter?
Why does having all this
physical infrastructure matter
and give you tangible benefit?
Well, a good way of showing
this is our premium tier.
So Donald had a really,
really good statistic,
which is that 99% of our traffic
is being handed off directly,
so really meaning
that it's going really
all the way across the
internet or across the span
between source and destination
on the Google network,
on this very, very fast
very high performance Google
network.
Now, our standard tier, this is
the way most cloud stuff works,
most cloud provider works.
If you're a routing person--
I'm from Ireland so I
say a rooting person,
but I've had to learn
to say routing person.
So if you're a
routing person, this
is the difference between cold
potato and hot potato routing.
Cold potato routing is you
take the traffic all the way
on your own network.
That's a premium tier
hot potato is you hand it
off as soon as possible.
OK.
This makes a really
big difference.
If you have premium
tier enabled,
you're getting a ride
on the earliest ingress
point on the Google network.
And Donald showed you the scale
on all of those locations.
You're coming all the way
across the Google network
to your compute, then all the
way back across the Google
network and then off.
If you're doing
the standard tier,
you're pretty much coming
in closest to your compute
and then you're being handed
off back to the internet.
And you're taking your chances
with the wider internet
after that.
Now what does this mean
in terms of performance?
Well, it's a big deal.
Don't take my word for it.
I actually work for Google.
I'm going to tell
you it's great.
But look at the actual external
folks that test this stuff.
This is Cedexis.
This is actually I pulled this
data just from last month.
The graph doesn't
actually start at zero.
It starts at three.
So you're talking about 1.9x
greater throughput going
directly across that network
as opposed to going across
and taking your chances
with the wider internet.
And that's what
you would expect.
If we build is really,
really high performance
network with all these fibers,
and all this cable, and all
this reach, you're going to
get much better performance.
So that's the premium tier.
Now very easy for
you to enable that.
Simply inside your
console on your VPC
is you're just going
to enable premium tier.
You don't need to go messing
with all this fancy routing.
And that's a big
message here that we're
able to make all of this
technology very, very
easy for you to access.
It's very complex at our
end to make it all work.
I actually worked in networking
for the last 10 years
before I came over to product.
Right.
But in terms of how it works
for you guys as customers,
it's very, very easy for you
to access this and turn it on.
So let me just put
three of those products
together as an example.
Let's talk about that
premium networking.
Let's talk about VPC.
And let's talk about
global load balancing.
OK.
VPC is your virtual
private cloud.
I'll talk about that
a little bit later,
but essentially this
is your main network
construct that you build, one
of the first things that you
build.
Here's something to know
is that that is inherently
a global construct.
Right.
You might use it on a
regional basis initially
but that's inherently
a global construct.
Now let's talk about
global load balancing.
When you enable this global load
balancing at Google, what we do
is we give your service
a virtual IP address.
But then instead of having
to play around with DNS
or doing anything like that,
we do this a much better way,
which is we do anycast.
So from all of our edge
bots on our extensive edge
infrastructure, we will
anycast out that address,
meaning that that same
address is advertised
in all these different
regions, meaning that you will
be pulled in at the
most proximate location
on our global network.
Right.
So here's an example.
We have Maya in California.
She has pulled in
directly to the US West,
which is on the west coast.
We have Bob in London going
to the same address which
you have your map to your
primary DNS A record.
And he's been sucked
into the London site,
so for very fast
local performance.
And then you have Shen
in Singapore again
using the same IP address DNS
going into the Singapore pop
there.
That's what global
load balancing does.
Now, because that
VPC is also global,
it's able to do this
very clever stuff,
like know if certain aspects
of your system are overloaded,
it can automatically redirect
to others and overflow.
Right.
So very, very clever and
very, very easy for you
to use the power of this
enormous network turning it
on like that.
Let's take this diagram here.
And let's imagine
we rewind it a bit.
OK.
So I don't have an
animation or anything,
but let's just pretend
we're not at a stage
where we have US,
Europe, and Asia.
Let's just say
we've just set up.
Just to begin with,
we've just set up
with a few VMs on
the west coast.
OK.
So what I can do, turn it on,
do this global load balancing,
set up my VPC.
And what's happening there is,
well, just all of the traffic
has been sucked
into the west coast.
All right.
Then what I decide is
I'm really growing here.
I could really use a
presence in Europe,
or the east coast, or wherever.
So I set up in Europe.
Now, because the VPC is global,
because global load balancing
is global, just by setting
up in Europe automatically
all that European traffic
or all the traffic proximate
to that region is
being pulled in there.
And then similarly with
that growth in Asia.
So very easy to make use of this
without very advanced knowledge
of the underlying
infrastructure.
The other pillar I
wanted to talk about
is performance at
the Andromeda layer.
So this is the network
virtualization layer
that all of this
stuff works within.
OK.
So this is this layer on
top of our infrastructure
that's going to give you that
performance and functional
isolation where your
infrastructure lives.
OK.
Let's first talk about
this idea of a VPC
or a virtual private cloud.
This is the basic building
block of your infrastructure.
So this is what you define.
And what you could
think about there's
something similar to a network
you set up in your data center.
This is your own little
private slice of the cloud.
And a good thing about this
as, firstly, as I said,
it's not region locked.
It's global.
Now, if you have
a situation where
you're in financial
services or medical
and you need your stuff
contained within a region,
yes, absolutely we
can do that as well.
But the concept
itself is inherently
not something you need
to define in each region.
Replicating that config,
you can define it once.
You also don't need a
VPC for every project.
You can do this
idea of a shared VPC
where you've got a
services VPC and then
you got host
projects off of that.
So very easy way to maintain
one common security model,
one common administrative model.
All of your traffic within
that VPC is very, very secure.
It's not touching the public
network, the public internet.
And, as Donald said, you have
all those 134 plus points
which you can interconnect.
OK.
So common overall
model using this
VPC as the base
networking block.
Oh, wrong button.
So this is what it does.
This is what the Andromeda does.
It essentially takes all of
our huge infrastructure, all
those data centers, all
those fibers, all those pops,
and chops it up so that you
have your own slice of it.
It provides that security and
that functional and performance
isolation.
So here we can see we've
got the green customer,
yellow customer, and
the red customer.
They're all using
10 space addresses
but that doesn't matter because
they're all completely isolated
and all working independently
within this Andromeda layer
using our infrastructure.
OK.
So how does it work?
Well, in terms of
what we do is we
push a lot of the networking
all the way to the host.
In fact, we do
that in user space.
We push all the way
down to the user space.
Why do we do that?
Well, firstly, it's very secure.
The data plane is
not running in route.
Secondly, it's a
very low footprint
so we can really
test it, fuzz it.
A very small surface
for any kind of security
vulnerabilities.
Very high performance
in a single processor.
We're getting three
billion packets per second.
For core processors then
we'll do more advanced packet
rerouting and things like that.
But a fast pat through
a single processor
gives us this very,
very high performance
without needing to rely on any
ASICs or any specific hardware.
It allows us to
iterate very quickly.
Allows us to do
hit list upgrades.
Allows us to do live migrations.
Allows us to continually
innovate and push features.
This is the overall
architecture itself.
The control plane itself
was built as a hierarchy.
You have a cloud
cluster manager.
You then have a fabric
management layer.
You then have the
open flow layer,
which we push the configuration
down to at an SDN level.
So fully replicated.
Fully sharded across
zones, across regions.
And by using that SDN and by
pushing the configuration down
into the fabric, that
allows us to really do
this horizontal scaling.
And that's a very--
let's think about it like this.
Think about our
internal load balancer.
Right.
Now we have all these
different load balancers.
We talked about the global
load balancer earlier.
I'm now talking about an
internal load balancer
within your slice
of the data center.
Actually, how you
normally implement that is
you have a dedicated box
or a dedicated machine
that does that or a
dedicated VM that does that.
We don't.
It's all existing within
the switch fabric.
So it means there's
no middle box.
There's no choke point.
It's configuration pushed
out into the SDN layer which
gives you that load balancing
capability so it gives you
this near infinite scaling.
This is an idea of some of
the level of performance
we've gotten with
Andromeda over the years.
So one of the main things
we've tried to look at
is the cycles per byte in
terms of transmitting traffic.
As we've gone through the
various iterations there,
we've had very, very significant
levels of improvement up to 16x
and up to 50 byte per
cycle improvement.
The biggest jump was
to Andromeda 2.0.
And we put most everything
into the guest layer,
bypassing the host.
Andromeda 2.1 we got
rid of the last tread.
And Andromeda 2.2 we
added memory copying.
And we continue to
innovate very aggressively.
Just since we talked to you
last at the last Cloud Next,
let's see we've introduced NPLM,
longest prefix matching caches
per machine.
So for internet heavy workloads,
that makes a big difference.
Our Hermes system for
network configuration
pushes is now twice
as fast, about 15
seconds to push the network
config versus 30 seconds
a year ago.
We've dealt with 2018 was
there was a lot of very, very
large CPU issues.
Specter, mind meld, et cetera.
We were able to deal
with those very,
very easily in the
background from you.
A lot of scaling in
our load balancers,
particularly using something
called hoverboards.
So we're able to scale
those load balancers quite
a lot further than way were.
And look, one thing that all
these improvements are leading
to, higher performance
devices for you,
higher performance services.
So at Next here,
we'll be announcing
the 32 gigabit per second VMs.
Limit before this was
16 gig per second.
Going all the way up to 32
now in your Skylake machine,
that's in all regions.
With 16 VCPUs, you get
all the way up to 32.
And that network is going to
give you that performance.
Up to 100 gigs on our GPU level
machines too going into alpha.
So if you have one of these
high end GPU machines,
you want 100 gig for that,
talk to your account rep.
Now let's look at how
we manage and monitor
all of those solutions.
I'll hand you over to
my colleague Manasa.
MANASA CHALASANI:
My name is Manasa.
OK.
Here we go.
My name is Manasa.
And I'm going to
talk to you about how
we monitor our network.
You heard from
Donald earlier about
how we build our global
network for resilience.
And you heard from Dave about
our investments and innovations
to be able to drive
for better performance.
And I'll talk to you
about how we monitor
our internal
infrastructure to begin
with where Google has
a way of monitoring
our network at various levels
in starting from intrazone,
interzone, inter-VM,
to the edge, and so on.
But we'll also
talk through how we
think about monitoring how
our end users experience
the services that get
deployed in Google Cloud.
And then we'll
also go through how
we use all these
metrics that get
generated to be able to
optimize our service delivery
parts to our end customers and
plan for the future as well.
So, with that,
let's get started.
Every machine on
the Google network
is actually a part of an
overarching monitoring
infrastructure.
We collect near real time
logs on each of these cores
that we have.
So it includes metrics
like RTT and throughput.
And this does not require
any additional software
to get installed in
any of the hosts,
so it comes at no additional
performance impact to you.
What this enables us to do is
it enables us to monitor and get
visibility into
our infrastructure
at various levels.
We can get metrics at the
VPC network as a whole,
or for a specific subnet,
or drill down all the way
to a specific VM instance
on a virtual interface.
Apart from this
collection infrastructure,
we've also deployed probes
extensively across our network.
And this provides us with
additional visibility
into things like
packet loss, latency,
and various other metrics.
So Google has overall
built a network
where the network
and the host actually
play well together to be able
to optimize for performance.
We built this centralized
bandwidth allocation algorithm
that's able to actually enforce
policy at the host level.
And all of this works at
the scale of Google land.
For those of you who are
interested in learning more
about that, check
out the publication
that we have called
bandwidth enforcer.
And you should be able to
get to know more about that.
OK.
Moving forward, like I mentioned
let's talk a little bit more
about how we think about
understanding how our end
users experience services that
get deployed on Google Cloud,
because from an end
user point of view,
they don't really care where
the network issues are.
Right.
It might be at the Google end
or external to our network,
but they just want
things to work.
So we at Google need
to think about it more
proactively to understand
where the issue lies
and work with our
partners proactively
to be able to
manage those issues.
So we've built an
infrastructure in technology
where we're able to understand
connectivity issues from end
users coming into
Google's network itself
and be able to attribute
that specifically
to where that issue lies,
be it at Google's end
or outside of Google's network.
And that enables us to
work with our partners
and minimize the impact to
end users, be it our end users
or our cloud
customers' end users.
And as you can
imagine, a lot of--
we serve about a billion
plus users with this network.
And they are dispersed
geographically.
So we're collecting
all of these metrics
from all corners
of the internet.
So what do we use
these metrics for?
First and foremost,
we've built models
goes to be able to
detect and alert
about fault conditions
or near fault conditions.
And then we take
all this data to be
able to provide a feedback
loop and optimize our service
delivery paths to our customers.
And we also then
take this data to be
able to minimize the time
we spend on troubleshooting
and mitigating issues.
And over a longer time,
we collect these patterns
and understand these patterns to
be able to plan for the future
and understand to be able
to plan our traffic growth
and capacity as we go forward.
So we talked about the
metrics that we collect.
We talked about how we use them.
But let's talk a
little bit about how
we measure these metrics.
Over the past few years,
as platform density
has increased to go
to include thousands
of physical interfaces, and
as the deployments themselves
have changed, we have
started to collect metrics
that the number of metrics have
actually grown exponentially.
Right.
So traditional protocol
based methods like SNMP
and syslog don't really
work much anymore.
For example, a typical
dynamically provisioned app
could have been spun
up, served its purpose,
and been shut down well
within a five minute time
span that is included in
the SNMP polling cycle.
So that makes our network
operators run blind.
So we needed a better solution.
So what we did was we
worked with industry leaders
like Arista, Cisco,
Juniper to be
able to advance the state of
the art in device monitoring.
We have been working to
build and standardize
streaming telemetry as
a replacement for SNMP
and syslog like architectures.
And streaming
telemetry, what it does
is it provides a high fidelity
data in near real time
performance to be able to help
us optimize for our traffic
bots and provide more real
time performance metrics.
We also work with
ISPs is worldwide
to be able to provide them
with near real time performance
measurements.
Google maintains a global
footprint with a generally open
peering policy.
And we provide access
to the Google ISP portal
to operators who share
the direct network edge
relationship with us.
With this ISP portal, what
our operatives are able to do
is they are able to get
insights about how exactly
Google's sending
traffic and why that's
the case to those specific
partners, how we together
can grow, and specific insights
into actionable metrics
actually into how
to improve delivery
quality, and performance,
and things like that.
So what you see here
is actually a part
of a snapshot of our
Google ISP portal.
And you can see that what
we provide is basically
ingress and egress
traffic breakdowns,
performance metrics like RTT,
throughput, even video quality,
and all the way go down
to providing our partners
with capabilities to be able
to actually predict what
the traffic growth looks like.
So we've also been--
we also have ongoing
investments on the product end
where we want to share more
and more of these metrics
with our cloud customers.
I'll talk through a few
of these products today.
The first one of them is
load balancing telemetry.
So load balance and
monitoring helps
you get visibility into your
internet facing applications
and perform diagnostics
around that.
It includes measurements
like number of connections,
latency for both the front
end and the back end,
and throughput.
Let's talk about VPC flow logs.
Think of VPC flow logs
as equivalent to NetFlow
for GPC environments.
We are able to monitor
everything that comes
in and out of the compute.
It's near real time without
any performance impact to you
when you turn these on
in your GCP environments.
And you can again measure
things at the VPC network level
or drill down all the way
to the VM instance level.
Firewall logs.
So, basically, firewall logs
help you to get visibility
into every connection attempt
against a firewall rule that
had logging enabled.
So you will be able to
audit or perform forensics
on all the connections
that got denied or allowed
over a longer period of
time to figure out patterns.
And you can consume all of
this information in Stackdriver
or export it to some of
the third party tools
that we have deployed
today in the environments.
We have integrations with
some of the major partners,
including Splunk, Sumo
Logic, and many more.
You can go check those out.
So in summary, you heard
about our resilient network.
You heard about the innovations
and investments here
and how we monitor it.
Here are a few of
the other networking
sessions that you might
be interested in that
are relevant that are
going to take place
over the next few
days and a link
to our networking
blog in case you're
interested in following us for
any of the future announcements
in the space.
[MUSIC PLAYING]